le premier jour j'arrive en france à la
gare de montparnasse
je débarque et voilà je regarde à gauche
et à droite tellement de monde super du
jeudi bolt dans une ville où on les gens
sont à cent à l'heure
chaque cours ils ont surpris si c'était
pas facile d'aborder quelqu'un je viens
je
voilà je me suis dit tu dois prendre le
métro 12 donc il faut que je trouve tout
de suite une solution pour ne pas
traîner dans
un gars comme ça et j'avais aussi y
avait énormément de vent
après ça je me tourne vers une personne
qui monsieur qui lisait un journal
français
excusez moi je voudrais pas le métro
nous mais je sais pas comment ça marche
il est où après dit il faut faire ça il
m'a montré où il faut y aller
et puis je suis allé je suis venu au
guichet dire un homme je dois aller à
marcadet pour rencontrer monsieur qui
draine énergie pour le début je viens et
je vois que les gens ils viennent y
passer je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire je reviens je ja plus là ça
saoule pas je fais des allers retours je
sais pas comment une fusion il faut mais
entre temps il y avait un autre monsieur
qui m'avait repéré il a vu que j'avais
des difficultés et puis niveau là il
devenait m'a dit monsieur c'est lara
mais tout ça me semble voler et danser
comme si j'étais dans un trou paumé rae
et là j'arrive bien prendre le tunnel et
je n'ai toujours pas vu la lumière parce
que moi je ne suis jamais habitué à
l'intention des espèces comme certains
grands sous la terre donc en guinée un
des tunnels mais c'est juste quelques
mètres s'est passé et là j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme si c'était
toute une ville mais combien vu que les
gens marchent bien tranquille je me suis
dit ok voudrait que je suive aussi et
tout le monde
dans les tunnels je marchais à gauche à
droite je vois des sdf les clochards des
français en plus en plein coeur de paris
et tout de suite je me suis dit que ça
va être très dur que je l'imaginais et
là je sors arcade et c'est la première
fois je vois le ciel de paris
ça criait à gauche à toison ne
comprennent rien presque parce que tout
se faisait à la hâte
tout à coup je vois des policiers en
civil qui débarque qui ramassent tous
tout ce qui était commun dit à des gens
qui ont fui ce domaine des marchandises
mais heureusement je n'avais pas une
apparence de quelqu'un qui le faisait
parce que j'ai eu peur aussi bien pour
ça va je suis resté calme et j'ai
compris qu'il y avait pas mal de sans
papiers et vous ça m'a tout de suite dit
montrer aussi l'importance de tout faire
pour avoir ses papiers sur tout ça parce
que moi ça a été mon premier souci
jusqu'au jour de la délivrance donc
savoir d'où ça m'a monté tout de suite
que je n'ai pas droit à l'erreur il faut
dès maintenant que je commence le
dimanche pour le savoir mon statut et
voilà je me suis croisé avec le monsieur
est venu au niveau de son petit bureau à
château rouge et de te dire compris que
ce n'était pas ce que j'imaginais je
comprends tout de suite qui comprend
tout de suite que le mec me va pas mais
berger je reste jusqu'au soir voilà j'ai
fatigué j'ai fait j'ai envie de dormir
mais à part se coucher il m'amène dormir
à nanterre préfecture
quelque part dans un petit hôtel où il
était avec eux c'est pas un ami ou quoi
je sais pas comment ça marche et livia
et voilà il me
dit ok si tu passes la nuit dit ok et
j'ai envie de toucher a pas de savon et
à rio j'ai envie de manger à rien
c'était juste le livre voilà tu di bao
kinh tranquille j'ai vu pas mal de
choses plus dures que ça et après tout
ça je suis allé chez son cousin où il
m'a hébergé pour commander h pour les
démarches et où je suis resté tranquille
et j'ai commencé ma démarche
entre temps voilà je suis allé aussi
voir une amie française et c'est parti
de là l'église a commencé à changer
petit à petit j'ai commencé mes
démarches avait beaucoup d'attentes un
peu partout mais voilà et je me suis
intégré j'ai rencontré des gens et aux
finitions obtenu mes papiers
et puis voilà déjà l'essentiel était
acquis quoi aujourd'hui je suis gérant
de commandes dans un salad'bar mais je
suis surtout comédiens et danseurs en
même temps donc je fais pas mal de
projets avec l'atelier des artistes à
l'exil
et en plus de ça je fais aussi pas mal
de figuration dans les longs métrages
comme dans les courts métrages des
séries télévisées les émissions de télé
un peu partout en france
donc voilà j'essaye de
l'un de vous est tout j'aime beaucoup
faire allusion à mes débuts
souvent quand il oublie je me dis c'est
quelque chose qui me je sais pas mais
c'est comme si c'est quelque chose qui
m'est précieux j'essaye de ne pas
oublier du tout à chaque fois c'est
quelque chose qui en tout cas qui me
permettraient je ne me rappelais de
comment je suis aller en crescendo
jusque là où je suis donc voilà c'est
comme ça j'ai j'aime beaucoup il penser
des fois
[Musique]